scenes captured from a live camera show
the coldest temperature ever recorded in
the continental United States at the
Mount Washington Observatory and
Research Center in the state of New
Hampshire where the wind chill dragged
the Mercury down to an incredible minus
79 degrees Celsius on Saturday
the Arctic Blast has brought Sub-Zero
temperatures to large parts of the
Northeastern United States and Canada
temperatures across the region plunging
to dangerously low levels in Boston
Massachusetts where it hit -33 with wind
chill the biting wind made the cold at
times downright painful if you're really
into
masochism and whatever uh yeah it's
absolutely great otherwise people say
what the hell am I doing here people are
used to cold weather here in Boston this
time of year but this is unusual the
last time it got this cold in Boston was
1957.
parts of Maine it was so cold there were
Frost Quakes small earthquakes caused by
sudden cracks in Frozen soil
elsewhere the brutal cold complicated
the emergency response to a massive fire
after train derailment overnight in Ohio
freezing the water being pumped to
Firefighters icy roads have made for
hazardous driving in some states like
here in Oklahoma
but back in Boston temperatures began to
creep up slightly in the afternoon
reaching negative 12. people began to
come out and brave the elements having
some fun but this is certainly a deep
freeze that people here won't forget
anytime soon
Gabriel ozando Al Jazeera Boston